[Musik]
nein
wo ist dann einfach nicht werden mit
jedem beruf nicht reich ich finde das
ist auch immer eine frage wie man lebt
also verbrannt die lebensstandards und
ich lebe von meiner herde seit herbst
aber er klebt auch sehr sparsam also ich
leben am existenzminimum
aber ich mache diesen bogen aus
leidenschaft und ich möchte auch nicht
auch noch machen
[Musik]
mein name ist schon abreißen 38 jahre
wohnhaft in duisburg den seit 2000
bereits selbstständig mit meiner
schafherde mit allen tieren zusammen 380
tieren und bin hauptsächlich halt in
oberhausen und bottrop ist mein kleines
plateau jabloner die seit gestern habe
von der mutter die drillinge hat dann
wird die kacke und da ein paar sorten
fleisch
[Musik]
die berufswahl thema gibt's verteilter
10.000 jahren also zumindest der
berufsschäfer wie fern die damals
gewonnen sind weiß ich nicht aber der
beruf schäferei ist einer der ältesten
berufe aber ich mache noch nicht solange
ich meine seit 2013
deutschland hat schon immer
wanderschäfer gehabt hauptsächlich in
süddeutschland und norddeutschland
balance wieder ruhrgebiet gibt es auch
schäfer sogar in duisburg schäfer gibt
schon noch werden jetzt wandern weiß
nicht wie ich hätte ihm am rhein steht
kann ich jetzt nicht sagen aber ich
kämpfe ein zwei kollegen die waren auch
noch im winter ein wanderschäfer wandert
hat das ganze jahr über egal ob sommer
wie winter sind halt im sommer oder
winter im tal und sommer oben auf berge
nahe und ich mache er seine
standortgebundene koppel unterhaltung
also ich habe meinen stall
ich habe meinen festen sitz wo ich bin
und von da aus die ich haltlos und bin
halt immer zu hause in meinem bett und
wanderweg ganzjährig zieht die haben
ihren wohnwagen dabei oder bauwagen also
und kennen halt da drin
ich bin wanderschäfer geworden
eigentlich durch den hund drauf gekommen
ich hatte 2001 einen schacht google auch
ein alter hut
und da schüchtert mich gefragt ob ich
die traurigkeit macht und die besteht
darin dass der und arbeitet und zeigt
dass er arbeiten kann anna erde und da
habe ich eine woche weiter kiefer und
mitgelaufen dann bin ich auch ganz viele
umwege gegangen und hab da 2013 die
möglichkeit gehabt familien dahlen mich
mit 30 tieren anzufangen
und jetzt bin ich heute 180 tieren wie
man im hintergrund hört
bei tagesablaufs jahreszeitlich bedingt
in der langen zeit ist mein haupt
arbeitszeit
da arbeite ich halt von teilweise
morgens sechs bis nachts um zwölf im
sommer den landtag vorbei ist entweder
bin ich hüten
dann fange ich morgens um halb neun
anfahrt zum stoff versorgt da die tiere
sie wasser für die schafe ich habe 1000
liter tank auf dem anhänger stehen macht
ihn voll fordern zur herde gibt ihr im
wasser
denn ich bin gut ich halt und dann zu
den schafen raus und wir nahmen acht bis
zehn stunden mit denen in der sterkrader
heide und arbeite mit meinen hunden
lasst die schafherde ableiten
[Applaus]
abdecken nach jeden tag den ich arbeiten
seit ich bin jude gebiet flügel heide
ist frei und ich die acht bis zehn
stunden dabei mit meinen arbeitsstunden
und klaus die gewalt in bestimmten
gebiet fressen und die hunde sind heute
praktisch dass nicht nur leben das leben
im netz der unterschiedlichen toppings
die koppel haltung gegen die scharfen
elektro netze mobile elektronik sie die
man auf und abbauen kann und in einer
hütte haltung sind die schafe frei als
ich die wir aus der koppel raus lasst
die freilaufen und dafür habe ich ja
meine güte und gehen mit mir die bmi
schafe wieder zusammen halten oder in
dem gebiet wo ich sie haben will halten
da sie halt grenzen kennen und wissen
dazu den weg frei halten sollen und die
vegetation grenze erkennen und je halt
darüber laufen können eine hauptstraße
seien an dem platz bin ich letztes jahr
habe ich anfragen von bottrop ich hier
die fläche offen halten möchte mit
meinen schafen also landespflege
betreiben möchte und hier habe ich
früher doch einfach mal aus habt oder
nicht wieder mit den anwohnern klappt
und so weiter und so fort und will jetzt
die erste woche hier und im großen
ganzen klappt auch ganz gut
die kindergärten dort kamen nicht
zustande weil ich hier bin hat sich
rumgesprochen schäfer hier ist mit
ganzen schaden und ein kindergarten
steht ansässig und kommt mit halt immer
regelmäßig vorbei und ich habe
vorgestern einfach mit eingebautem einer
arbeit und habe mit ihnen die ganzen
kleinen lämmer in die nächste koppel
getrieben und habe hatten wir spaß und
ich hatte weniger arbeiten oder
leichtere arbeiten so
ich arbeite sieben tage die woche 365
tage im jahr
auch nachts wenn es sein muss mein handy
ist immer neben mir aber auch immer
abrufbar also bin ich immer zu erreichen
im notfall dabei ja wissen sämtlichen
wichtigen stellen ein krieg ja das mache
ich was mache ich vollzeit mäßig war
dachte ich immer zu hause aber ich habe
nie so weit weg dass ich beim tafel
schlafen müsste ich mach das schon mal
in ausnahmesituationen wenn ich die ganz
neue flächen habe und ich merke da gibt
es viel ärger viel glauben die leute es
gibt ausbildungsplätze es gibt zwei
schulen einmal in halle an der saale
blockunterricht und in süddeutschland
gibt es natur und de wenn man im betrieb
geht wurden meister und käfer meister
die können ausbilden und haben hast du
halt ein teil praktika in betrieb und
hast dann 16 wochen im jahr
blockunterricht und die ausbildung geht
halt ganz normal drei jahre und dann am
ende meiner theorie und praktische
prüfung also als ich angefangen habe
waren wir am anfang 30 und nach
anderthalb januar die hälfte warum die
jungen leute sich die männer
interessieren weil ich glaube dass diese
generation nun anfangen will nicht
arbeiten aber viel geld
das funktioniert halt nicht aber die
werden auch sofort der band rennen bei
jedem anderen arbeitnehmer weil wenig
arbeit und viel geld ist halt nicht in
dieser gesellschaft wer geld haben
möchte oder arbeiten von nichts kommt
nichts
verkaufe patenschaften seit 2013 also
die patenschaften sind ganz große
einnahmequelle für mich weil die haben
wir einen fahrer eigentlich finanziert
der pate teil einmalig 100 euro erhält
dafür eine patenschaftsurkunde mit einem
tier sich entweder aus suche also ein
weibliches lamm oder auch ein älteres
tier wenn man möchte
und da jedes hier in deutschland nur
einzel die erkennung hat haben die alle
eine ohrmarke meiner zahl drauf und die
wird halt in die patenschaftsurkunde
eingetragen plus der name den der papst
sich aussucht ja das ist wohl die
partnerschaft verkauf oder andere sind
halt die scharf aktie nicht noch habe
der aktionär es halt auch einmalig 100
euro und kriegt ihn innerhalb von 18
monaten lammfleisch im wert von 120 euro
kilo preis 10 euro von mir zurück ich
glaube dass der beruf schäferei
perspektive finanziert immer schwieriger
wird
da die politik eher wenig bis gar nichts
macht und sollte den nächsten 15 jahren
mit der weide hier prämie nix passieren
glaube ich dass dieser beruf aussterben
wir in deutschland
[Musik]
sehen nämlich nicht nach zeit wohl
ziemlich sein kann ich kann für mich
sagen ich am leben bin ich habe auch
immer mal wieder wochen wo ich sehr weh
zu tun haben wo ich netze stecken wasser
geht und dann eigentlich nichts mehr zu
tun habe klar ich habe mich drei wochen
urlaub wie andere di angestellt sind
aber bei jahn ich gewinne weller reise
durfte ich noch irgendwie möchte ich in
andere länder ich bin froh beim ein
schaf und man nun wenn ich noch meine
freundin beiden wir brauchen gut ich mag
meine schafe ich mag meine hunde und ich
mag es in der tour zu sein am liebsten
auch alleine ohne menschen
und ja es ist das soll ich machen möchte
und machen will mit ihren arbeiten mit
schafen arbeiten und mein arbeits und
inhalt die schafe geben ganz viel wieder
und dem was ich ihn gäbe also ich gebe
ja auch ganz sicher geben wir ganz viel
wieder nämlich ihr vertrauen sie laufen
hinterher wenn ich anrufe wenn ich komme
direkt an wenn du mein auto hören kommen
sie an und gucken da kommt aber ganz
viel wieder und das ist das ich nicht
missen möchte
[Applaus]
[Musik]